[Music]
hey
everybody you are here it's wednesday
yeah we decided to do a side tracks
today because we were going to watch a
movie last night but then we got all
we got all involved in all these weird
food shows yeah
on netflix sophie introduced us to a new
series we probably had to talk about
yeah we saw the whole thing didn't we
yeah because there's only yeah there's
only like four or five episodes because
we started out watching
i guess there's a new one on there
called taco chronicles yeah it's like
two
well it's two seasons but i hadn't heard
of it and they just put the second
season up
yeah so mexican yeah so we watched like
the first couple things of that and that
was like really good but then sophie's
like oh there's this crazy japanese one
that's on here
that you have to see that's called what
is it called it's called
hyper hard-boiled gourmet report
yeah heart hyper hard-boiled gourmet
which is the most
japanese title i think i have and it
doesn't has very little to do with food
it's tangentially about food i guess
they use food to try to figure out about
[ __ ] weird groups of people like
african child soldiers that are living
in assembly so i think that was some of
general butt naked's
yeah general butt naked former child so
because it was in liberia
yeah and then they used food to kind of
track down and see what uh
middle eastern refugees are eating when
they're on their way
going through the balkans uh then they
get into the crips and the bloods down
in la they go hang out with them that
was it was actually the crips versus uh
florencia
that's right florencia it wasn't the
bloods weren't in there
but it was kind of good because
everything's from that damn japanese
perspective it's kind of
they're shocked by everything you know
well the funniest thing to me was that
it's it's really it's not like crazy
over the top like a lot of japanese
shows
are but it had like a lot of it had like
big
words across the screen like a lot of
the time and it was all in japanese so
he couldn't read it
even though it was like um you know
subtitled and [ __ ] like what they were
saying
but during the whole entire show the guy
who i guess
is the producer is he the producer like
the guy he's he's just in a circle
up in the corner the whole time and he's
like commenting on everything and so
he's always making noises like
like what's going on on the screen
because he's not the guy that actually
goes to the place
like he's not the guy that actually went
to liberia or actually like went to
south central or
you know all the other places that they
went to that's like some other dude
but this is the dude that just like sits
back in this
studio and just like reacts to
everything that he's seeing it's like
the weirdest thing
it's funny is that that that that the
japanese
hosts and i guess the audience just
believe
everything they're told without question
like they're
they're in la and they're talking to
people who are just getting out of
central lock-up
men's central lock-up or if you guys
know how
jails and prisons work you don't do a
lot of time in a central lock-up you're
not
in a real prison you know what i mean
you're not going in a penitentiary
so usually you're there less than 60
days they're talking to guys who are
getting out like
old guys that don't have any teeth and
never like when
he told them that he'd been locked up
since he was nine
well initially he said he'd been in for
three years that they were letting him
out
that he had been in there for three
that's right and they said when were the
first time you went to prison because i
was nine the first time i would
you you don't go to prison at nine
there's just all kinds of goofy [ __ ]
unless he meant like nobody knows he
meant
prison he was just he was just lying
that's how bad it is
to
[Laughter]
chinese food foreign instead they buy a
mexican food and he's eating burritos he
didn't really know the difference
he didn't eat well i don't think he
really cares he's just like food's food
whatever
and he i don't think he had been in
there for three three years more
probably more like
30 days yeah and it's like well they
couldn't really get a straight answer i
don't know
like what do you want therefore maybe
even just a couple of days
maybe it was just something embarrassing
yeah
you know they get in there and they bond
out and get a court date and they and
they
like yeah that's like not worth it
that's not where they sense that's just
kind of like the holding
it's a whole place like before the
central prison either let you out or
you know send you on to send you one of
those a deeper prison right that's right
but it's just funny the way they were
going i mean it's a fascinating
concept for a show that these are kind
of like
you know these people that you wouldn't
really think about
you know what they eat but this guy was
apparently like really interested in
that
because he's like everyone gets hungry
so he figured
i'm just gonna go like ask all these
people like and it wasn't
it seemed like i don't know if this was
something in the translation but i think
it was saying like what do crazy people
eat or something i think it did say that
a couple of times it's like i don't know
like the translation i don't know if
that was correct or not because not all
the people were crazy it's like they
talked to
you know like i said they just talked to
some like refugees that were
you know trying to like leave in
pakistan or whatever they talk to like
this woman
in africa who had survived ebola
like her whole family had died of it and
like she was you know they're still like
what does she eat and all this other
kind of stuff
so it's like everyone wasn't a crazy
person but they did like try to
concentrate i guess on criminals
essentially
like gang members gangs yeah that type
of stuff
they weren't real bad guys though most
of them seemed pretty okay
to be honest we were talking talking to
one guy
i think it was from valencia was from
the valencia gang
and florencia is the name of it again
that was called florencia
florencia yeah he had never done any
serious jail time and in fact he
he legally posses he pulled out an ak 47
in a box with [ __ ] his pistols and
stuff
but if you understand the situation he
he legally owned all that that's
grandfather
grandfather claus even in california it
was pre-banned it was an old pre-banned
narinco
worth a lot of money but the japanese
were [ __ ] just shocked they were just
like oh my god
because he had tattoos and he had that
damn ak
which is weird because they went and
talked to like people that were in the
yakuza and they're like all covered with
tattoos
so it's like why is that weird to them i
don't i don't know if it was like
tattoos i don't know if it was like not
necessarily weird to them or they were
just like trying to make a show out of
it like oh my gosh look how shocking
this is or maybe
maybe that was like the funny aspect of
the show was like the dude that's like
up in the corner the whole time like
reacting everything like going
oh like disapproving oh [ __ ]
we were laughing like when they first
got to l.a the the
internet interpreter whatever he was one
that was going to show him around
he's like hey how's it going the first
thing he said is those are ak bullet
holes on that wall
and look i got shot like last year
this is the first thing he told the
japanese people yeah and they're like
jaws
yeah so the dudes were like showing off
like it's like i'm on a tv show like
look how bad look i got shot it was like
you could barely see it look like
somebody winged him in that elbow
i mean that's not good i'm just saying
that it's not like he got shot in the
heart and survived
i think a lot of it was just stories
yeah well yeah i think a lot of it was
but i i found it really really
fascinating like you said they didn't
they didn't go as much into the food
as maybe i mean they did
but a lot of it was just kind of like an
anthropological the liberia episode was
the best one where they had the child
soldiers living in the damn center they
lived in a cemetery and then there was
a female child soldier in there who's
got good [ __ ] muscle insertions and
nice arms and she's [ __ ] hooking
and they he she takes the japanese guy
out to her
places where she seems like a lovely
woman yeah she seemed normal yeah she's
funny her name was lofty lofty yeah she
was trying
and then she goes out there and only she
gets a dollar fifty for turning the
trick
and takes a dollar fifty and goes out
and gets some rice and potato greens
it looks like collard greens yeah you
know looked like southern food you know
it did i've never had potato greens and
the japanese guy ate some of it that was
filming it and he said it was pretty
good yeah
i mean it looks pretty good yeah and it
was a lot for how cheap it was
yeah it was like a big huge pile of rice
because she said that that was the only
like
meal that she got they're all good they
were all good episodes that go into
russia and stuff it's just the one that
oh yeah that's right
the one that stuck out yeah they were
they go the one that stood out was a
liberia one
for me yeah it definitely did i think
that's the best one plus they got
pickpocketed they got pickpockets
although he gave their [ __ ] back he gave
it back
he kept the pen though they were playing
with him they were playing with them you
know i mean
they had cameras and were trying to get
in into the cemetery to take pictures of
you know all the child soldier retired
child soldiers living in crips
and they were definitely showing off for
the camera oh dude oh yeah they were
they were they were they're like hey
look at this skull this is a real skull
they're like yeah it came from a body
it's a cemetery it's of course you pick
pocket and dude
i'm sorry it was an accident my hand got
hit
but he gave it to you that was awesome
and he gave him his pen back it was just
those pins it has the yeah multi i think
they just said keep it i don't know yeah
yeah we've got millions of them got
stuck that's all
yeah yeah they're all just a bunch of
thieves and pick pockets and hookers and
stuff
well that's what they drink money like
they buy food and crack
that's the best one and then they sleep
in the crypts in the in the [ __ ]
cemetery and then the bones then they go
to uh
to go meet siberian jesus up in russia
oh that's right i forgot about siberian
jesus yeah they gotta they gotta
up in siberia there's a [ __ ] there's a
they got a fake they got a fake jesus
he's evidently a reincarnation he looks
very jesusy
i'll give him that much they built a
little santa claus village what it looks
like
look nice it did actually it looked like
a [ __ ] christmas card or something
from
christmas those people it's funny
because i guess they were trying to
you know like i said that's why that's
why it was a little weird that they used
the word crazy because these people yeah
you could say it was a cult and
everything like that but most of the
people looked pretty normal
i don't know if siberian jesus was
normal because they didn't talk to him
like maybe he was some [ __ ] up
individual but everybody that was in
this group
seemed okay like it didn't seem sketchy
or anything
they were all carpenters right and they
had built like all the houses that they
lived in and they were actually like
really really nice
yeah louie's talking about grandfather
and then the aks
yeah it was a pre-banned narenco from
the 80s
all right and then they the supreme
court just overturned california's uh
assault rifle magazine ban so
everything's on the table you can have a
30 round magazine there now so all that
shit's
getting thrown out uh you can't ban
there is no such thing as an assault
rifle it's got to be full order to be an
assault rifle
where they have that [ __ ] all defined
it's [ __ ] crazy
mango badger says sushi yakuza the name
of my new food show i've already
copyrighted it
right yeah
zach says excuse me siberian jesus yes
he looks like him he's pretty
he did like i liked his red robes it was
kind of like uh
siberian jesus crossed with the david
cronenberg's dead ringers it was kind of
like that it was
like a red kind of thing but they didn't
um they couldn't
talk to him i don't know if he like
wouldn't be on camera or whatever but
it's like everybody
in the village like had pictures of him
like on their walls and i was cracking
up because the one house
they had the calendar like one of those
you know kind of 11 by 17 like glossy
calendars with a calendar on one side
and then like a big photo
of siberian jesus on one side and he's
like leaning against the wall looking
very savior-like like with the sun
behind his head and everything and i was
like
looking all serious it was funny hey man
[ __ ] hiss
his [ __ ] um what you know his photo
shoot game was [ __ ]
it was top-notch i have to say you know
he's bringing the siberian jesus game
with each [ __ ]
photo shoot oh definitely he knew what
he was doing yeah
but he wouldn't he wouldn't make an
appearance he didn't want to talk to the
japanese
i guess he's not like he wanted to be he
didn't want to be ridiculed
evidently yeah maybe not or maybe he
wanted to like retain his mystique
yeah he did he did that's what i mean he
looked a little young to me jesus didn't
he
he did yeah i couldn't actually tell how
old he was he looked like he was 30
yeah i think i think he's older than
like i said i listened to a podcast
about it but i really can't remember the
details i think he's a little bit
okay different but yeah i think he's 11
30.
i think he just looks good or those are
old pictures yeah maybe but we don't
know what he looks like the japanese
didn't like it
you said that the japanese don't like
calls they're they don't like put off by
calling they're called
put off by cults well rightly so most of
the time because a lot of them are super
sketchy
this one i'm just saying that they
talked to the people and the people
seemed
normal they didn't seem like weirdos or
anything the japanese don't like
religions
they just don't like them especially
more than you you're talking about
in in the rural areas they they they
don't understand them they're not raised
with that
yeah i can say that they don't eat
because shinto shinto is not really
[ __ ] they don't they're not big into
shinto like they were
you know in in in the 40s and shinto is
like kind of just
like a bunch of animism it's it's not a
centralized religion where there's a god
that created everything yeah that's not
in it it's like a bunch of little
folklores
folktale stuff you know the kappa might
be in it remember the copper yeah yeah
he might be in it
all of the yokai monsters yeah the yokai
monsters might be like the umbrella
monster with the foot and the tongue
there's you know the chick with the
super long spirits
magic dogs and [ __ ] like that you know
there isn't uh
just a bunch of folk superstitions
really
yeah yeah mango says siberian jesus
sounds like a cradle of filth
track well actually i was thinking of
that bad religion song american jesus
which that's what it reminded me of zach
said um speaking of food did i ever tell
you guys about my sister's cookbook no
you have not
but you should what kind of cookbook is
it
we gotta we gotta work on we gotta work
on ourselves we gotta finish our cooking
we gotta finish our cookbook cause like
i said i want it done by the end of the
year god damn it so we still have like
two or three more months
but uh yeah yeah kind of yeah um
he says isn't christianity still big
there though and buddhism
no christianity is big and korea it is
yeah
and i'm not i'm not even sure if i'm not
even sure if buddhism is really a factor
in
in japan you'd probably have probably
not anymore you have to check
but what's funny is that you know a lot
of these a lot of these countries will
have
religious traditions like when it comes
around burial and
in marriage and maybe certain holidays
but other than that you know it's like
we celebrate christmas but how christian
is christmas
you know something with easter how
christian is it
that's that's two or three different
things happening at once there's a
corporate version of it
there's kind of it's based on a pagan
idea not
christianity then there's a been
christian
kind of laid over it you know
superimposed over it so what kind of
what kind of
holiday is it it's also a federal
holiday
and you know the united states is
secular so why is it recognizing these
religious but i feel like a lot of
people just celebrated in a secular i
mean i always laugh because i didn't i
didn't grow up i was gonna answer
why we do it because rome did it yeah
basically
rome did that same thing it had its
secular
games and secular [ __ ]
holidays that were based on [ __ ]
roman cults
even though they were secular yeah
because it was both at the same time
they didn't take it that seriously yeah
it was just well it's just a fun
traditional they're homaging things yeah
i mean it's like oh it's
you know the the height of winter like
spring is coming soon it's like a big
festival
everybody can get together there's food
there's presents it's like oh it's going
to be warm again soon
hooray it's that kind of thing so it's
like i can see why that
why there have been holidays like
celebrated around that time of year like
everywhere around the world for like
thousands of years
yeah um zach said look up the butcher
babe by l'oreal gavin she was on the
food network
okay i will actually that sounds pretty
cool that you know what you talking
about the um
funerals or burials and stuff reminded
me of that other thing that was on
oh yeah that show that was it was in
tibet right
uh nepal or nepal yeah yeah where they
had
um you know they you know where they
have the barrels and they like put them
out on the
you know by the side of the river it
wasn't the ganges but it was like an
offshoot
yeah i think it was like a tributary or
something and it's like and they burn
them and you can come out there and see
it
and they talk to the guy that was like
one of the
uh crematorium guys like the body
burning dudes
and then they talked to this little
these little kids
and their job i guess was to go
out and they would like trawl in the
water like after the bodies were burned
and they scraped all the ash
of the people into the water and these
kids would go and tr
like trawl through the water like
looking for coins and gold teeth
we fished for honey that's what she said
and she was eight
she was like the cutest little girl and
she was just like in there this like
filthy like
corpse water yep like but she
seemed like okay with it i guess i mean
that was just like well that's our life
so they were living in [ __ ] bad
poverty
they were so they care yeah i guess it
was like it was nice
but yeah it's um anyone remember [ __ ]
in kitchen
i don't what was that all about
sounds like a bunch of surfers trying to
teach you how to [ __ ]
[Laughter]
this shit's bitching man everybody's got
got a [ __ ]
well if if you're gonna have a cooking
show because so many people have a
cooking show and so many people have
a cook book you need to have an angle
man just like the [ __ ]
you know black metal vegan black metal
chef has
where he you know he got popular on
youtube because he [ __ ] not only like
made everything vegan and had all the
you know black metal [ __ ] on but he also
wrote a song for everyone that told how
to make the [ __ ]
yeah you know so like i said you gotta
have an angle so
uh you sound like you're kind of dying
down
he's winding down i've just got these
allergies going on i got
pookie uh got it way up in my nose and
i'm like
residual effects here yeah like hold it
together without
snuffling i was mad because i i was
thinking about turning my amc
20 a month back on i was thinking about
turning that back on and going to see
[ __ ] peninsula nestled the train of
business
the thing is it's like it was at amc
theaters it's at some of them still
but it's been out for like a month like
more than a month
so it might have played at ours and i
just didn't realize what's planning ours
right now
um anything good damn i don't remember i
i know ten it was new mutants uh there's
some other stuff and they're doing like
some old
movies they're doing like close
encounters they're doing um empire
strikes back they're doing like uh
jurassic park like they're
you know show them on the big screen
like special event types i'd love to see
close encounters again
that would be kind of cool yeah i have
to look up the date
you never seen it at all she's never
seen close encounters at all yeah that
was
not
don't available and it had really good
special effects for the time
it did actually wow seeing alien ships
yeah ufos coming to earth and building
the [ __ ] out of mashed potatoes yeah
well the aliens didn't do that
right possessing people's minds
richard dreifus and a little kid what
was his name [ __ ]
running out through the damn doggy door
and the aliens grabbed him
yeah that's right what was his name
barry barry
come back his mama's running barry no no
aliens have the best ice cream right
oh i wonder has anybody ever made a
movie that was like uh
kind of a mix-up mashup between like an
alien evasion movie and ice cream truck
horror movie
because there's several ice cream cones
has ice cream in it
that's true and they're from space
that's
where that's what i was thinking i love
that movie
yeah i love i've seen that a million
times that's one of my favorites
but trying to remember is it the the
hook with the ice cream are
they're like made of no they're not made
of ice cream there's like ice cream
that is at the end though too yeah they
kind of they melt one of them gets
melted or something yeah
i think so i just saw it like a few
months ago yeah i can't remember
oh i don't know how bad i can't remember
the end i know i can't either
like i remember [ __ ] man yeah i remember
the popcorn
guns and the cotton candy like
i don't remember which component goes
where i know that's right
but you know i res what i love about
that was that it's so low budget
but the production design was just so
[ __ ] cool looking like they just went
all out with that [ __ ] like the inside
of the ship it's like it looks amazing
and the clowns look amazing yeah all
right so uh
somebody said it's time for tom's old
man now oh yeah
yeah she doesn't her hair is short but
uh if you touch her it just goes
like little cactus things she ran up
next to her
what can i get from you what can i get
from you yeah it's like do you love me
also
do you love me what are you gonna do for
me that's what she does
well i get her i get a daily head butt
you only get one though
so it's usually like in the evening like
after i've kind of like taken a shower
and then i sit down on the bed
and then she jumps up on the bed and i'm
like head butt head butt and i put my
head like that and she comes and goes
doink
yeah and then she goes and jumps off and
goes and does other [ __ ] but like i said
she won't do it twice she just does it
one time
but she knows what headbutt means all
right so that'll do it for our
side tracks next live stream is gonna be
saturday night my big birthday live
stream
we're going to have cake and hats yeah
maybe i don't know
dennis might have a hat now that his
head is back on
pookie might have a hat although she'll
probably take it off and eat it
um but yeah it should be fun and it's
it's gonna be
like a fun uh topic we're not doing like
a super depressing topic this time so
it should be a good time so uh we'll see
you guys
again live on saturday night have the
right good rest of your day
bye